Un carpintero está usando un torno
para darle forma final a la pata de una mesa
que está hecha a mano,
y realmente un torno,
si podemos recordar,
es una cosa que gira y que es una máquina
que utilizan mucho los carpinteros,
justamente para darle
formas cilíndricas
a por ejemplo,
la pata de una mesa,
ahora para lograr que embone,
necesita ser de
150 milímetros de ancho
permitiéndole un margen de error...
un margen de error
de 2.5 milímetros
y es que en la práctica, pues aunque uno desee
que la pata sea de 150 milímetros de ancho,
pues siempre ocurren errores,
errores humanos,
errores de precisión
¿Qué sé yo?
Y lo que sí nos dice es que bueno,
uno puede tener un error
pero que no pase
de 2.5 milímetros,
es decir, que el ancho de nuestra pata no sea
más de del ancho esperado por 2.5,
ni tampoco menos.
Escribe una desigualdad
con valor absoluto que modele esta relación,
y luego encuentra el rango de anchura
que puede tener la pata de la mesa.
Así que para eso voy a definir nuestra primera variable, que le voy a llamar "a"
y que "a" va a ser el
ancho de la pata de la mesa,
en la pata de la mesa,
muy bien, esta es nuestra variable "a"
y lo que tenemos,
es que si a "a" le restamos 150
en realidad estoy viendo
qué tanto se...
qué tanto se diferencian
los 150 milímetros que yo estoy esperando,
que mida el ancho,
y con el ancho al final
que me queda la pata.
Ahora bien si "a"
es más grande que 150
tengo que esta diferencia es positiva,
si "a" es más chica que 150,
tengo que la diferencia es negativa,
a final de cuentas yo... a mí lo que me interesa saber
es la cantidad exacta
por la cual digamos se diferencian,
así que basta con tomar un valor absoluto
que con esto me está midiendo el error
que cometí al hacer... al hacer la pata.
Y este error me dice que debe ser menor o igual que 2.5,
muy bien entonces,
ya que tenemos esta relación,
sabemos... sabemos de vídeos anteriores
que cuando tenemos un valor absoluto
menor o igual que un número,
esto simplemente se traduce
a que "a" menos 150,
debe ser más chico o igual
que 2.5,
y debe cumplirse al mismo tiempo
que "a" menos 150,
sea mayor o igual,
mayor o igual que -2.5,
así que vamos a ir resolviendo esto,
vamos a hacerlo simultáneo,
vamos a sumar por ejemplo 150 en todos lados.
Si lo hacemos de forma simultánea
sumamos 150
en todos lados y
¿qué es lo que me da?
En la primera esto se cancela y me queda que
"a" debe ser menor o igual que 150 más 2.5,
esos son 152.5.
Por otro lado me queda de este lado que
"a" debe ser mayor o igual
que 150 menos 2.5
y esos son 147.5,
y con estas dos relaciones
ya podemos dar un rango,
porque el ancho por un lado debe ser
menor o igual que 152.5
y por otro lado debe ser
mayor o igual que 147.5,
y recordemos que realmente queríamos encontrar
los valores del ancho que podíamos tener
y pues es bastante intuitivo,
que si, que, que...
que tenga valores
entre lo menos que puede tener
y lo más que puede tener,
de hecho aquí son
150 menos 2.5
que es el máximo error que podemos tener,
y aquí 150 más 2.5,
que es también el máximo error
que tenemos hacia arriba,
entonces si queremos calcular todos los posibles valores del ancho de esta pata,
basta expresarlo en términos del error,
el error simplemente
es el valor absoluto de esta diferencia,
y no debe pasar de 2.5.
Separamos en dos desigualdades
como ya habíamos visto en vídeos anteriores,
realmente aquí es tratar
de entender el concepto del error,
y al resolver
de forma simultánea estas 2,
2 desigualdades
obtenemos finalmente nuestro rango
y este es precisamente el rango.
Los valores van de 147.5
a 152.5.